quanto preoccupati siete personalmente
del cambiamento climatico in una scala
da 1 a 10
quanto preoccupati siete del cambiamento
climatico e del riscaldamento globale
dunque uno poco 10 tantissimo bene
dunque
tra le date del si parla relativamente
poco del cambiamento climatico
se pensate ai media se ne parla poco in
paragone diciamo quanto si parla di
trump quanto si parla del break suite o
della riforma costituzionale sui social
media se non avete degli amici veramente
appassionati dal tema anche lì è raro in
fondo che notizie appaiono ma quello che
più sorprendente quanto poco se ne parli
diciamo a casa con gli amici a un tavolo
degli studi in america dal sel
communication centro di yale mostrano
che 70 per cento degli americani non
hanno mai o molto raramente parlato di
cambiamento climatico diciamo nel nella
nel loro cerchio prossimo di amici
questo praticamente sorprendente perché
adesso non so i vostri risultati ma
negli ultimi anni è molto chiaro che il
livello di consapevolezza rispetto ai
cambiamenti è molto elevato siamo all 80
per cento nella maggior parte dei paesi
e quello che sta crescendo anche molto
molto rapidamente è anche il livello di
preoccupazione
immagino possa immaginare che
probabimente una buona parte di voi avrà
messo qualcosa tra nell'ordine tra il 6
e il 10 e diciamo a livello di
preoccupazione
allora perché non se ne parla perché se
ne parla poco
malgrado che ci sia questo livello di di
ansia in fondo un grande scrittore a
metà agosto c'e un po come parlare della
morte si cerca di non parlarne al 3
degli psicologi ci sono tanti psicologi
adesso che si stanno occupando di
cercare di capire la nostra relazione
appunto l'ambiente
dicono che abbiamo proprio un problema a
riconoscere negli altri questo livello
di interesse e preoccupazione evitiamo
sono una specie di spirale del silenzio
perché in fondo pensiamo che gli altri
non interesse dunque il richiamo di
parlare di cose che rischiano di
metterci in conferito riscono di
imbarazzarsi ecco quando si però ficana
se sia a livello del discorso di vero
del discorso personale questo non emerge
questo tarlo di preoccupazione però
rimane e se cambiamo il livello di
analisi iniziamo a guardare proprio ai
comportamenti e alle pratiche quotidiane
e io a me piace guardare proprio quello
che le persone fanno nel quotidiano
vediamo che le i cambiamenti sono molto
molto molto superiori abbiamo fatto un
paio di studi il primo uno studio
bastanza divertente che abbiamo fatto a
milano l'occasione del salone del mobile
di soccorso grande passaggio abbiamo
messo due grandi lavagne con due frasi
un po provocatorio per fermare il
cambiamento climatico io e poi c'è da
completare o stiamo uccidendo il pianeta
ma non riesco a non dunque visto il
flusso che c'è questa era la cascina
cuccagna sul flusso di geneve avuto
centinaia e centinaia di risposte ato
che ogni tot ore dovevamo cancellare
tutto dalla lavagna
quello che è interessante parla un
pochino a questo fenomeno del silenzio
diciamo progressivo che le lavagne si
riempivano di più quando c'erano già
delle cose cioè il primo riflesso lo
quello di andare a guardare il rilascio
niguarda vicino lasciateci guardare cosa
gli altri hanno scritto vedere cosa
altre persone facevano e poi e poi
completare ci sono dei pattern e quello
che interessati veramente son saltati
fuori centinaia di piccole soluzione
piccole pratiche quotidiane tante
intorno alla mobilità tante persone che
fanno della bicicletta eccetera
tante persone ovviamente intorno al cibo
poi delle cose divertenti cioè non ho la
vasca in italia quello che emerge molto
chiaramente è una grande attenzione
all'acqua l'acqua come risorsa preziosa
tengo l'acqua
l'avo di meno mi cerco di fare delle
docce corte eccetera e serietà dunque
dei temi ricorrenti poi tante soluzioni
individuali
eccetera ero un pochino una provocazione
ma era anche il momento di far partire
delle discussioni che abbiamo avuto in
modo abbastanza approfondito ecco un
altro studio invece che abbiamo fatto a
londra questo più di natura etnografica
che quello che io faccio in genere sono
andate a vedere diciamo poco di nuovo
guardare un po come come si svolge il
quotidiano quali sono le la vita
quotidiana e come le pratiche quotidiane
sono non certo senso informate o no o
influenzate o no da una certa
consapevolezza del cambiamento della
protezione sul cambiamento del clima
allora due parole di premessa sulla sola
vita londinese sicuramente sapete anche
voi un costo della vita allucinante un
corso delle abitazioni pazzesca una
crisi molto forte dunque dell'abitazione
per cui diciamo una grande proporzione
di persone soprattutto prima del periodo
della famiglia eccetera che vivono in
spazi condivisi dunque successo e si
affitta un appartamento insieme
questo è il punto di partenza che visto
anche però non solo come una soluzione
economica ma anche una soluzione sociale
e anche un in fondo a un primo passo
verso una specie di condivisione delle
risorse
ecco quando si parla di mobilità nessuna
delle persone con cui abbiamo discusso è
che abbiamo osservato in caso nessuno
possiede un'automobile è personale tanti
non hanno neanche la patente dopo il
mezzo di trasporto per eccellenza è
talmente piedi e trasporti in comune e
poi la bicicletta di nuovo visto i costi
esorbitanti del dei trasporti
londinesi la scelta della bicicletta
nasce per 4 fondamentalmente 4
motivazioni forti che sono un po poi il
tema che vedremo attraverso tutto
diciamo quello che in fondo a un pochino
tutte le scelte
uno è quello va bene dell'ambiente il
secondo chiaramente quello del costo e
sterzo molto importante quello della
salute cioè il fatto di fare esercizio
di muoversi eccetera
e il quarto è quello di una certa
autonomia l'autonomia il controllo un
senso di controllo sui propri
spostamenti
il secondo punto che dove stiamo vedendo
proprio una trasformazione molto molto
grossa e intorno l'alimentazione un po
come abbiamo visto in italia dunque una
crescita importante chiaramente delle
persone che non mangiano carne e poi una
crescita di quelli che vengono chiamati
flexitarian persone che hanno ridotto in
modo drastico la carne è però non sono
dogmatici cioè se vi capita di capita ma
non così e poi una tensione veramente
pronunciata all'origine del cibo c'è da
dove il fatto che non venga da troppo
lontano che non sia non venga dalla
nuova zelanda
eccetera eccetera specie di attenzione e
anche lì quando possibile diciamo cibo
organico dunque anche lì quattro fattori
c'è questo fattore di di controllo
maggiore consapevolezza su quello che è
la salute il costo e l'ambiente molto
molto forte
c'è una cosa che sta succedendo a loro
molto interessante che la scomparsa una
cosa un po per persone anziane sono gli
allotment gli orti gli orti condivisi
ci sono 25 anni di attesa nella maggior
parte di boa dei bonus per avere accesso
a uno come avevo incontrato un po di
persone appunto che lo fanno se non
riescono fanno crescere cose varie in
sui loro terrazzi anche lì qual è il
tema il tema è quello del voglio provare
voglio provare cosa vuol dire far
crescere qualcosa voglio tentare di
tentare che cosa che qualche cosa
comportano certo senso di spirito di di
conoscenze i consumi ecco forse anche di
un cambiamento veramente radicale cioè
il moto la parola chiave è sempre stata
poco ma di qualità
la lotta contro la quantità
a bassissimo costo lo lavo due volte poi
dovuto perché di pessima qualità
eccetera tutti ci dicono poco ma di
qualità qui ci ritroviamo anche con è
fatto di avere spazi condivisi per cui
la possibilità di un accumulo molto
inferiore fatto di muoversi in
bicicletta per cui di non trasportare da
lontano eccetera
però una coscienza molto forte abbiamo
sentito tante volte la frase tutto
energia noi mangiamo co2 tutto tutto
quello che abbiamo prodotto con una
fortissima coscienza equivale a una
micro parentesi perché c'è un discorso
molto forte da parte degli economisti
che tutte le nostre scelte e tutti i
cambiamenti di consumi sono
essenzialmente dovute la crisi eccetera
qui quello che abbiamo osservato è
veramente una posizione morale se volete
una posizione rispetto a un cambiamento
del modo di consumare profondo poi
un'altra cosa sempre nei consumi l'idea
del ciclo un ciclo su quello che
interessa in un certo senso avere delle
cose che possono non solo durare che
possono essere riparate che possono
essere passate avanti qualcosa che sta
funzionando moltissimo a londa questo
sono questi servizi di free cycling o un
tavolo cambio casa mette on line il
fatto che questo tavolo è disponibile
qualcuno passa a prendere lodo via e io
stesso cambio casa cerco un tavolo vedo
on line che cosa c'è tra una specie di
ciclo di ciclo di molto più lungo del
del consumo
ecco è un tema molto forte nel quale
appunto le sensazione di autonomia e
molto invece non è presente e quello
dell'energia tante persone appunto per
le loro condizioni di vita per fatto di
condividere di essere in condomini e
città dicono ci piacerebbe cambiare le
nostre fonti di energie ma non possiamo
siamo un pochino succubi a quella è un
tema che che è presente a fare delle
cose di questo genere e collegarsi a una
fotovoltaica oppure cambiare
ecco quali sono un pochino le tematiche
cioè le parole chiavi che abbiamo
sentito chiaramente c'è una parola molto
forte che quella di precarietà che non è
sulla precarietà economica ma proprio la
specie di precarietà assoluta cioè
precarità dell'ambiente precarietà di
esistente ecc
e a questa si oppone molto fortemente
l'idea di un tentativo di recuperare la
propria in inglese hagens il proprio
controllo la quota possibilità di azione
e tanti di questi modi sono dei modi di
recuperare in un certo senso l'azione
propri hanno sentito tante volte la
parola di risorse e di responsabilità le
due cose che vanno insieme cosa posso
fare scelgo una risorsa su cui sono
responsabili però quello che è molto
forte e il fatto che tutte queste
dinamiche tutti ci hanno parlato del
fatto di quanto sono personali queste
queste azioni cioè quanto in fondo sono
individuali come dicevo non c'è un
discorso pubblico per cui la gente si
sente relativamente sola e non certo
senso questi in queste piccole azioni
che fanno a livello quotidiano
quello che è interessante il fatto che
l'azione per sta precedendo il discorso
c'è un discorso pubblico che in un certo
senso è molto più ritardo rispetto
quello che sono le azioni individuali e
c'è uno scollo allora noi un'antropologa
digitare dopo mi occupo di digitale
credo che il web negli ultimi 20 anni
abbia avuto un impatto molto forte sui
suoi comportamenti e da due che abbiamo
creato qualcosa per cercare di mettere
insieme e di facilitare l'azione questa
piattaforma la potete provare quando
avrete il permesso di tirar fuori
telefonini di nuovo si chiama beta e
juventus
cioè se volesse vuoi e quello che fa
raccoglie migliaia di servizi per
aiutare l'azione integrazione
sostenibile dentro di tutto
da ex per condividere viaggi a mappe per
sapere se il proprio tetto è orientato
nella direzione giusta ha modi di
trovare dare via cibo eccetera eccetera
e geolocalizzata se guardate ci sono
parecchie cose anche in questa regione
c'è in lombardia c'e tantissimo ma
quello che è interessante è che tutte
queste tutte queste questa base è stata
costituita da una comunità cioè la gente
continua giorno dopo giorno si
propongono delle cose ci mettono dentro
delle cose è quello che stiamo cercando
di fare in un certo senso di dire no non
solo agevoliamo l'azione se non solo
permettiamo l'azione di trovare
dei modi di fare delle piccole azioni
individuali ma anche di cercare di dare
in un certo senso uno spazio comune di
discorso appunto visto che le che il
discorso è assente e le reazioni che
abbiamo sono proprio di questo genere
c'è qualcosa non sono solo c'è qualcun
altro che sta facendo qualcosa matt
howard su una cosa divertente che posso
fare è questo lo scopo non certo cercare
di ricongiungere un senso senso l'azione
al discorso è riconoscere che le nostre
azioni stanno andando più velocemente
grazie